but guys is actually what everyone's
fridges gonna look like in about two
weeks
oh my god don't say that knock on all
the wood you see so close
nope you're like a hair away from it
though you got a baby
Oh careful with Oh
how did the movers get it in through the
front door what can I do to help
cuz they're here now I can hear the
truck I'll tell you guys right now
that's right
I'll take it up for you yeah see I see
you guys serving yeah we tried owner the
first battle scars to the house I know
well there's quite a few already with
the move okay was so funny because we
did not want to pay the extra $25 just a
super cheese okay oh my god now that I'm
saying it out loud I'm like wow no cuz
we were like oh we could just get a
dolly like the foldable dollies and then
we could have a dolly around the house
cuz it's always useful having a dolly
and then we ordered the dolly but the
dolly is not coming until like a week
from now so then we went to aunt's house
to go borrow his dolly so we could move
the fridge ourselves and you just saw
the the catastrophe of that luckily a
delivery guys seemed really nice and
he's like go to where I'll move it for
you
sound like something like okay just add
it to the bill so a sticking our old
fridge and by the way can I just say I
have had this fridge since I was 20
years old so over ten years it was my
first we're not my first but one of my
first pieces of like independence so for
many years I've been saying I need to
get us a new fridge
a new fridge especially in the old place
it just looks so ugly and that's the
reason why I wrapped it in like this
stainless steel contact paper it had a
makeover because I was like well maybe
you could just bake it in the meantime
right thank you yes
but then now that I'm actually letting
go of it oh my oh I'm ready but it's a
little sentimental it's kinda like my
car like when I cried for my car like
now I'm like oh I'm not gonna cry for my
fridge but you know that those same
emotions come up yes the last one right
last farewell this really is yeah I mean
some like decorative like those mirrors
out there and stuff like the black
mirrors that we had in the living room
as part of it too but those that I am
purchased myself I actually got them
from my mom but yeah this is like the
last piece of my initial independence
that I purchased myself and now it's
time to say goodbye or reliable I got
her at IKEA
so IKEA you came through for a good 10
years and it actually still works it's
just that now it's time to upgrade so
yeah I'm not too mad at it because it's
going into good hands and it's planning
on keeping this refrigerator in his
garage so at least it's gonna still be
put it to you so still gonna be kept in
the family so it's okay but I'm really
excited for the new fridge though
[Music]
all right look at the new beauty she's a
beauty look at this what a beauty
well we gotta set it up but dang we
could fit way more food now look at this
this is nothing compared morning my boy
it's an early day see look look look at
looking looking looking looking
oh man I pointed to the refrigerator
instead of your face dang it no no no oh
yeah right doesn't this is way way way
better than the dinky one and see it's
not contact paper anymore it's actual
actual stay little see yeah we actually
have a fridge second I know finally it's
like nice and flush to the wall yeah I
was like right here me too
you know now it looks pretty see the
dishwasher the stove the microwaves
oh yeah I saved stuff I saved this one
for you Isaac so you can kill it see if
you know that's my favorite sound so do
you want do you want to feel anything
oh these are clean like that yeah check
it out see we could make coffee in this
fridge Wow Yeah right there try to find
the edge oh nice catch oh see that's
even easier hey Joe
he's like what is this what we got here
he has complete a scent on it see look
he's like well I'm starting from the
trash see I'm working my way
not took place yet what are you doing
I'm making sure I get every single inch
of this stuff because that's how for
myself thinking of the word anal I
didn't want to say anal so I guess that
angel I don't know what's happening with
me I'm just trying to get every little
piece because I'm very anal like that I
don't know I'm kind of like going
overboard because I'm even getting in
into the rubber like this is gonna be
covered but just knowing that it's there
can a father be like that sometimes but
I already scratched up the fridge a few
times over here oh yeah it's okay can't
tell it's like so low like right here
hmm I'm only angel about things whenever
I'm working on things but once I'm done
working on it and it's like an
afterthought then I'm no longer an angel
yeah you're right I'm devil about it
yeah it's just like with the stove bill
there and now that I'm thinking about it
I think I'm gonna want some done here
I'm gonna go over there but for all this
time no I forgot that it was there no
angel on it yes I wish they would put
the plastic over the metal after they
put all these things on the edges
it'd be easier eat that plastic all
right I finished tell me what you guys
think baby
this is amazing they really have
upgraded refrigerators these days look
at this this thing slides in so it could
be space for the tall stuff all the deli
stuff is in here the fruit the veggie
this is gorgeous and then also there's
this drop-down tray if we ever need it
for whatever reason look at that but you
can set to talk country yeah just in
case you didn't know they have to go on
a another grocery run you know right
right for a bigger family we we honestly
are because I used to think with the old
fridge and I was cooking and I was like
I think like we can't have a bigger
family I know there's like no room
there's three masses feed already here
and I'm like having a little more food
in here that's so true you know what my
most favorite thing about this new
fridge is the fact that there are lights
here everywhere and there is no possible
way you will be blocking the lights
because in the old fridge we only had
one tiny little lightbulb here and then
for some reason you always loved to put
everything that could block the light
for the rest of the fridge I'm gratitude
I know you really are good luck put it
there yeah cuz I'm like you can't see
the rest of the fridge because you're
blocking the light but now we're not
gonna have that problem while I put it
everything there's no possible way for
you to block the light that's why I am
so in love with this fridge yeah look
there's even lights up here like there's
no way your blog like didn't know the
show has it hasn't how do you open this
powder go yeah I said it's a deli and
then I love how you could put fit the
gallon and the door oh I just noticed I
did not finish this angel mode yes angel
mode I'll be doing that in a second the
way the freezer look how organized this
is this is beautiful oh my goodness and
then look there's like a
extra shelf being here so to put other
stuff oMG I love it this is it this is
the last part of us feeling like
grown-ups hug finally grown up so you
got a grown up fridge and we can also
make coffee with our fridge and you set
that up like there's a little coffee
symbol and then we can start the brew
and then look how cool is it look at
that and it's perfect timing because
your parents are coming in tomorrow oh
so they get to come to the new house and
a new fridge that's true they'll be
buying groceries alright so here's the
old fridge we're trying to defrost it
before and it takes it but this is a
lightbulb I was talking about it's like
right here so then KC for some reason
like to put everything on the top shelf
here so then that would leave the rest
of the fridge pretty dark man you did a
good job because while I was setting up
the new fridge KC was cleaning up the
old one or this one and he did a really
good job it looks really clean hey you
did a great job cleaning the fridge it
looks really really good
and then you're finishing this one up so
first coffee cup out of the fridge
that's kind of cool man living in the
future and also I connected my phone to
the refrigerator you see those Wi-Fi
thingy that's freaking nuts
how cute alright so I know what you're
thinking her eggs are bad it's bad for
the environment and I agree it is I feel
guilty every time we use one of the
disposable curing cups but we do also
use the reusable kind so I try to use
this as often as I can but because they
gave us a brand new like little trial
thinking of like a variety the Casey
wanted to try one of them so I just
brewed him a cup but I like I said I try
to use the reusable cup as often as I
can so we bought this thing has like
brown coffee so for the days that I'm
out in a rush like I have oh shoot I
really don't have time to like pack the
whole thing and then I'm just like I
need a go go go go go that's what I
ended up using one of these babies it
smells good so I had never set up a
brand new fridge before and apparently
you let it drain like the water lying
drain for like five minutes and it was
so gross because when Isaac brought over
a cup and he did it for the first time
the water was black I'm like that's what
that's what comes out of there but I
guess it's normal I don't know so I made
sure to drain out all the water and then
also like the air bubbles in the line is
the whole point as to why we have to do
it but the fridge is all set and we got
our first cup of coffee let me go
deliver it to mommy here you go
just that fast come yeah that's no
wonderful aromas of coffee mm-hmm yeah
Tom dedicated Carrie did I know that's
gonna be added to the pile of stuff to
sell mm-hmm and then you can control
this on your phone yeah
for me exactly we heat it up we should
we put a cup there the night before
well it won't dispense unless you hold
it it's just the the thong thing it's
just yeah it's just so we can prep the
water I know don't like try to make it
like all right now it's lunchtime we
ordered some Popeyes love that chicken
for [ __ ] bat nut sponsor and dang this
is good this is the first time I'm
having the sandwich that everyone's been
fighting over I get it
pretty moms at the same time I got a
text from Jess she has insider knowledge
that the government is preparing to be
shut down because remember the last
video where I was talking about the
whole like kind of semi apocalyptic
feeling that we're all going through
here so yeah apparently the government's
gonna be shutting down and they're gonna
issue like a don't go anywhere unless
you need to notice so extra time at home
cuz Isaac has a whole three weeks off of
school whoo yeah we're just trying to
make things a bit positive here
especially now I'm feeling a lot better
since we have food and we are stocked up
and you might be wondering like why are
you so ordering food if you have food in
the fridge well where you decided we're
still gonna be trying to order food as
long as we can and then save up the food
that we do have in the fridge for
worst-case scenario we're just trying to
prepare Casey went out to Home Depot
that's why he's not here if you want to
go get some parts for some stuff that
we're trying to do like mounting the TV
on the wall which we still haven't done
hopefully we get that done today that's
just a quick update on what's going on
on a second day of self quarantine kind
of not really because Casey's out in
public but you know what I mean
thank you copy oh come on you never sit
at the piano anymore and just seeing you
sit there and playing and having a great
time and made me want to document it I'm
sorry are you upset with me no
where'd it go hey Joe oh there hurts my
ear
[Music]
why are you guys so cute an tears
hey you're freaking up your fridge thank
you
yeah he has to disinfect it because
you've got a baby at home and a toddler
at home and a wife at days I've been
sick so I'm like dude I just can't let
this stuff to activated you know yeah I
don't blame you this is my own dolly I
know thanks for letting us borrow the
dolly you know it's funny we actually
didn't even end up using it because
because as we were trying to like pull
the fridge out from the door we couldn't
figure out like the angle it was really
weird so then hit a bit but then the
refrigerator guys they had like pulled
up here and then they saw us struggling
and they were like guys don't even worry
about it I got you like move it yeah so
they ended up like strapping it around
their waist like some like weird straps
and yeah
squat it yeah yeah thank you for letting
us borrow the dolly but it didn't even
get used it needed to be here anyways to
do this very good oh yeah you're right
thank you for not putting this yeah and
then ask you if you like and then also
the egg that came with the fridge the
egg trays in case you wanted so guys is
actually what everyone's gonna look like
in about two weeks
oh my god don't believe that not on all
the wood you see I'm stocking up on
storage there we go
smart yeah once the apocalypse happens
yeah you need somewhere to store it
well baby IKEA fridge yeah it's pretty
big but dude we got to show you our new
fridge it's so much bigger it's so much
nicer you showed everyone else yeah yeah
quarantine your face right here look
[Laughter]
just watch the blog watch the vlog see
like this is what you're missing out on
it
Crona symptoms but I don't know why how
come I never tested oh my goodness oh
wait
Joey wait like the Space Shuttle where
there's like that chamber that's not the
airlock
you want to get the core maybe I'm
wearing my slippers or else I would help
okay got my shoes on Oh high five
everyone
oh yeah you're right you're right you're
right oh yeah good idea good idea yep
wait all right so after ant took the
fridge we ended up going to his house to
help him unload the fridge into his
house you know it's funny because
Christina came outside and since they
have been kind of sick we were like I
had a really like an arm's distance
maybe even longer like far away from
each other trying to communicate with
one another we usually hug each other
when we say hi and this time we were
just like air hugs
it was awkward we came back home we ate
and then now Casey is trying to fix the
big day so ant tried installing this the
day when we first moved in but the
actual connection from the wall is like
a lot smaller than what the bidets
connection is I don't know for some
reason it's like a lot smaller right
yeah so then that's the reason why you
went to Home Depot so you could get a
little rubber piece to stop the leaking
but then after fixing the leaking
problem for some reason it's still
leaking though like it's not leaking
from the place that we thought it was
leaking anymore
but now it's still leaking we don't know
why and we're trying to figure it out I
don't know what do you think did you
were you able to taint it some more yeah
yeah I was the one that actually put it
back together and I put like all the
bidet stuff and I took this guy off this
is the one that came with the house so
this thing here for some reason it's
like a lot smaller than
the standard I don't know the standard
size so then that's when we got the
adapter and then we got a little rubber
piece thinking that that would be the
thing that would stop it from leaking
but it's still leaking so no no we're
considering calling a plumber at this
point because we've exhausted all of our
options plumbers are expensive so I
don't know your dad that's pretty handy
that's what you married me true with
everybody able to figure this out either
so I don't know but yeah all right
pretty handy maybe yeah maybe tomorrow
he'll help us
once they fly in that is because oh yeah
maybe you turn it off right there's no
noise there's no water noise Wow I don't
know maybe there's a way we can use this
thing still instead of you know the one
that's curling the curl the girls one
that's that's the same one for this one
I don't know we got to figure this out
now that we're homeowners this is this
is part of being an owner you gotta fix
things and troubleshoot them yourself or
you can just call the plumber but maybe
tomorrow Papa Chan can can help we'll
see and Isaac's just been chillin
watching some TV all day
it's enjoying his quarantine right yeah
Oh with Maya
Maya's nice and relaxed are you bored
mmm
at least you get to watch TV not deal
with this house madness yeah
[Music]